Yeah,
my name is mile.
It's so lovely to meet you all.
It's so lovely to see so many faces.
Herrick Google for me today,
it was a little bit nervous about this talk.
So I'm really grateful for a great turnout.
So yeah,
I'm an author and I'm a speaker and I help women primarily heal their
relationships with food so they can go on and lead fulfilled and enriched lives
without waiting to lose weight first.
Um,
and it's mainly women that I help and I believe it's mainly women that struggle
with their relationship with food because we tend to be more sensitive to being
led by our emotions.
In general.
We tend to be more intuitive,
um,
on a whole that's generalizing obviously.
Um,
but you might not even realize that you're in a relationship with food unless
you are in a really unhealthy one that is taking over your life in some way.
Um,
but actually your relationship with food is just as old as you are.
So if you are 30 years old,
your relationship with food is also 30 years old and your relationship with food
is really made up of all of your beliefs,
stories,
memories around food,
food,
and your weight and your body that you've had your whole life really could have
been something that someone said to you one day that triggered a feeling or an
emotion could have been something that you read,
could have been the latest Diet magazine you picked up.
And all of this constitutes this,
this huge relationship with food that you have.
And it probably doesn't come as a surprise to you to realize that the reason
that I got into doing this work and helping women with their relationship with
food and making peace with food was because I was in a really unhealthy,
quite abusive relationship with food for a long period of my life.
So I'll tell you a bit about my story first.
So I grew up never really having any issues around food or my weight.
Um,
my mum was quite healthy,
you know,
let us have the odd treat.
Um,
the household was very healthy.
My mom never criticized her body,
so I knew that she never dieted.
She was very much at peace and I was quite confident kid really loved my life,
was really happy at school,
had friends within the sports teams,
felt like my teachers liked me and I,
I really just was very carefree and I remember walking across the playground
once and you know like the girls at school,
like how bitchy that was,
you guys remember?
It felt like it was very catty kind of atmosphere.
And I walked across the playground and a girl from one of the years above me
said,
not directly to me but just loud enough that I could hear.
She said,
oh that girl now she loves herself.
And I felt like someone had punched me in the stomach.
I felt like that is like the worst thing that anyone could have ever said to me
or about me.
I love myself.
I was like,
how dare that girl that loves herself,
like no one wants to be that person.
And at that age you really just want to fit in.
You don't want to be too loud or too big.
Cause you just want to fit in.
And I remembered at that point,
remember that I remember to think to myself,
I am not going to be the guy that loves herself.
Anyway,
I was determined to be an actress and I left school and went to college at 16 to
be,
to do performing arts.
And when I got that,
it was kind of like this really harsh industry where it was really competitive.
Um,
and you're basically spending like eight hours a day in front of the mirror,
kind of being taught to look for flaws and imperfections.
It's a very perfectionist,
um,
industry.
And I was,
or ID and natural,
you know,
high achiever,
perfectionist,
which I'm sure probably some of you are in here.
And all the guys around me at college were pinching themselves in the mirror
going on these diets.
And I just really wanted to fit in.
So I basically started dieting as a way to fit in with the girls around me
because I didn't want to be the goal that loved herself.
I didn't want to be the one that was too confident and didn't need to do any of
that.
So I basically started dieting as a way to fit in and it was in that era of the
size zero thing it was,
there was no Kim Kardashian and there was no big booties and squats in any of
this.
Not that it is nowadays.
It was like that kind of size zero thing was really glamorized and it was a
really unhealthy environment for,
for teenage girls and for women to be in.
And I remember going on the special k diet,
does anyone remember the special k diet?
And you want to do it?
Oh my God,
don't read fall.
Yeah.
So basically the special k diet for anyone that doesn't know was a way to lose a
dress size in two weeks.
And basically you've got a bowl of special k for breakfast,
a bowl of special k for lunch,
and then you've got to have whatever you wanted for dinner magic.
Right?
Except it wasn't a bowl of special k,
it was like a handful.
Right.
It was like the smallest handful you could imagine.
And so I remember like measuring out this bowl of special k every morning and it
was literally like the smallest boy you could imagine and special k obviously
geniuses because they realize that if women were going to believe that special k
was their diet food,
then they were going to end up overeating and bingeing on special k,
which is exactly what happened before.
I knew I was getting through boxes and boxes and boxes of special k.
So me being a perfectionist and getting into diet culture at a very young age,
I,
it wasn't long before I took it to the extreme and developed a full blown eating
disorder.
I lost a lot of weight very fast.
Um,
I restricted myself so much that at one point I couldn't even remember the last
time I had a proper solid meal.
I was completely spaced out.
I went to a really dark place,
isolated all my friends and family.
But for some reason I felt like I was in control.
I felt like I was,
um,
making a success of this.
I thought that I was doing really well at this and I do believe that an eating
disorder is a form of addiction and that is absolutely how it felt.
So what happened next was I got offered this TV job is acting job,
which sounded like the most exciting thing ever to me cause I was 18 and you
know the thought of,
you know,
most of my friends were going off to drama school and Uni and taking gap years
and I just been offered this TV job straight out the gate and it should have
been a dream come true.
I took my whole life up to Liverpool,
moved out of my parents' house.
I suddenly had this flat,
I had money,
I was going out to these parties and I was getting to act every day on set.
It should have been the dream.
But you know when,
I'm sure you've heard this story before,
everything should have been great and it looked on the outside like it was
really glamorous.
But on the inside it was not.
It was that empty sinking feeling of all my God,
this is not it.
And my eating swung from barely eating anything to suddenly excessive bingeing.
And I'm talking like inhaling food.
Like I'd never seen food before in my whole life.
I was like inhaling it like it was oxygen and I felt such guilt and shame over
this and for gaining weight so fast again that I would then it swung into
bulemia and I would be making myself sick or overexercising taking all kinds of
illegal fat burners off the Internet and just really punishing myself so much
and then swearing to start the next diet the next Monday morning.
And my producer actually called me up to the office once and she sat me down and
said to me,
Mel,
we really need to talk about something.
You know,
your weight.
It's all over the place,
you know,
on screen,
one episode you're this size,
the next episode of this size,
the next episode,
you're back to this size.
Like continuity,
you know,
doesn't really know what to do with you in the wardrobe department.
I've got all these different sizes for you.
Um,
do you need to talk to someone?
And I thought I'd been doing a really great job of keeping it secret but
obviously not.
And it was so embarrassing to feel like everyone knew and I was completely
crushed.
And that night I went home,
run back to my flat,
got down,
sat on the couch and picks up the phone.
Hey yeah,
it's Mel.
I got an audit.
Three large pizzas please,
Yap stuff crest.
And when the delivery guy came,
I opened the door and he started laughing at me and he was like,
there's three beats is all for you lady.
You know when someone's like joking but not so I closed the door,
sat down with these pizzas and one by one at demolished every single one of them
until I was in so much physical pain,
I couldn't move.
I'd never felt so full and yet so empty at the same time.
And then I would of course swear to start this brand new diet and fix myself the
next day because diets are what would fix this right now.
You mightn't have never experienced an eating disorder or disordered eating,
but a lot of these addictive patterns show up in much more,
much more subtle ways.
How many of you guys have ever gotten home from like a really stressful day and
before you've even taken your shoes off,
you're like in the fridge looking for answers,
looking for that fix of something.
And I believe when we do those,
it's not the food that's the problem.
It's a symptom of a much deeper problem that we need to get to the bottom of and
heal.
You see,
if your relationship with food was a relationship with a partner,
what kind of relationship would that be?
For me,
it was a very abusive relationship,
not a loving one,
not a healthy one.
Maybe your relationship with food is really stale and really boring.
Maybe it's like really strict during the week and then it's just this crazy
party or binge on the weekend.
Maybe it is,
um,
really monotonous.
The same thing all the time.
Maybe it needs a bit of spicing up.
You see,
food isn't just nourishment anymore for us,
it isn't just fuel we make,
it means so many other things.
It's the closest thing to us that feels like a substitute for love.
So it's really easy to turn to it,
to control that when we feel out of control of our lives,
it's the easiest thing to turn to it when we're feeling emotional or when we're
feeling any kind of uncomfortable or painful feeling that we just don't want to
feel.
We want to escape.
And US humans are wired to seek pleasure and avoid pain.
So it's something that we're all doing all the time and it's not necessarily a
bad thing.
You know,
seeking pleasure and using food as comfort,
as reward,
as love.
It might have saved us a lot of pain and heartache,
but actually what it does is it doesn't actually take away the pain.
It just numbs it and delays it for later on.
And then we develop these unhealthy relationships with food and try and go on
diets.
Trying to fix them.
So if you imagine like an iceberg and the tip of the iceberg is the only part
that's above the surface,
the tip of the iceberg is like what you're actually eating day to day,
like what you're actually putting in your mouth.
But the whole iceberg underneath the surface,
that is your entire relationship with food.
The psychology of like why you eat,
how you eat,
who you are as an eater,
what your identity is around food,
all of those beliefs,
all of those memories and all of your relationships,
your career,
how fulfilled you feel in your life.
Because all of that dictates what you end up eating and your behaviors around
food.
So I kept thinking,
you know,
the perfect diet will fix this.
You know,
I just need to find the perfect,
when I found the perfect diet,
then I'll be healed.
You know,
I'm sure that,
you know,
my food combining is all off or I'm sure that I'm just having too many carbs
for,
I'm sure that I'm having too much fruit or too many good fights or whatever it
might be.
I'm sure that I'll find the perfect diet.
And then what happened was my dad was given four months to live and he was
diagnosed with terminal cancer.
And obviously this completely shattered me and completely shook my world.
And he started reading books on cancer.
You very intellectual and read so many books.
And he started reading about cancer,
knowing that he was dying.
Um,
and I started doing the same and because I was already obsessed with food books
that stood out to me where cancer prevention,
lifestyle diet,
and before I knew it,
I had been engulfed in some books that told me that veganism was the best way to
reduce your cancer risk.
So I was like,
oh my God,
this is it.
I found the perfect diet.
This has gotta be it.
This is my answer.
And I felt so much guilt and shame that I had found what I thought was the holy
grail too late to be able to save my dad because my dad was on these.
Um,
you know,
my dad couldn't even keep food down at that point.
So I,
so often he died.
I thought,
I've got to share this message.
I've got to go out into the world and tell everyone about veganism.
And because I was a perfectionist and because I still had disordered eating,
I didn't do this by Harvey.
I didn't just go vegan.
I went gluten free,
I went in fat free,
I went sugar free,
I cut out caffeine,
no alcohol.
I pretty much cut everything out until I was just eating fruit and veggies.
And even then I was worried my eating too many fruits because it's sugar,
isn't it?
So I still had this really negative relationship with food and I didn't even
realize until one day I discovered that I was bingeing on a tub of almond butter
and dates.
And I realized that I was still restricting by going on juice cleanses.
And I thought,
yeah,
I haven't actually fixed anything here,
have I?
My eating disorder just has another face.
And this is actually something that I see is really common,
um,
at the moment in the wellness industry is we take things a step too far instead
of finding peace with ourselves and peace with food.
So I realized this and me and my then partner,
we're having talks about getting pregnant and trying for a baby and the thought
of this was so un,
like such a new thought for me and it completely shook me because I remember
looking in the mirror at my body,
this body that I had spent years at war with.
I'm thinking,
okay,
if I'm going to grow a human in here,
something has to change because if I have to grow a human baby and here I know
that I can't keep treating my body the way that I am.
I can't restrict,
I can't be bingeing,
I can't be using food in these,
you know,
abusive ways.
I need to find a peaceful place with myself and with my body and with food
because I can't grow a human baby on juice cleanses and fruits and vegetables.
I can't grow a human baby if I'm bingeing on the weekend and then starving
myself in the week.
And then I thought,
okay,
if I wouldn't do that for a human,
for a child that's imaginary,
why would I not do that for myself?
Why have I not been doing that for myself all these years?
And I thought to myself,
you know,
you're not ready.
You're not ready for trial.
Do you need to focus on loving and nourishing your body without child first?
And if you can do that for a year,
then maybe we'll talk about it.
And so I went on this journey of self love and I chucked where my scales and I
basically started inspecting my relationship with food.
One belief at a time.
Every time I felt a fear or anxiety come up around a certain food,
I would question it and go,
where did this come from?
Is this truth?
Is this a story or belief that I want to keep believing and want to keep playing
out in my life?
Because at that time my head was so full of all of this overwhelming information
about nutrition and about which diet is the best.
And I was hearing this person talking about veganism,
this person talk about Paleo,
this person talking about quitting sugar,
this person talking about the Duke and diet five too intimate investing,
all this stuff.
And I was like,
Oh my God,
my brain is just full.
I just need to let it all go.
And it was just the most liberating thing ever.
So I want to just do a little exercise with you guys if you don't mind.
Um,
and it's about beliefs and it's about these kinds of diet,
culture beliefs that we take on as truth and then,
um,
express ourselves with.
So I just want to raise your,
I just want to raise a show of hands.
Um,
if any of these beliefs ring true for you or if you have ever believed any of
these to be true,
and there's absolutely no judgment by there because I believe all of them and
more so,
have you ever believed that food is the enemy?
Have you believe that fat and food will make you fat?
Have you believed that you should count your calories and Monday to Friday,
but on the weekends,
calories don't count.
How many have you believed that sugar is evil?
Cubs are terrible.
That one comes from the Atkins Diet.
I think.
Um,
how many of you guys have believed that if you have one bad food in the day,
you may as well write off the rest of the day because it doesn't matter,
right?
Just start again on Monday.
How many of you believe that diets have to start on Monday?
There's no other day,
right?
So now if you had a little girl or a boy and they came up to you and they said,
mom,
diets have to start on Monday or mum,
this food is bad.
And if I eat it,
I can just see all the rest of the bad foods and then start again tomorrow.
Or if they came up to you and they said,
Finn,
people are automatically happier people.
That's another one.
Would you believe that is healthy for your child?
Would you want that for them?
Would you?
But we,
but we accept that for ourselves all the time.
So my moment of transformation came when I thought about having a child and
suddenly my picture became bigger than just myself.
Because when you are like really consumed with food and diets and weight loss,
it's a really tunnel vision way to live.
You don't see the big picture,
you just think your,
your all,
you're only here to lose weight and get down to a number and then your life can
magically begin.
How many of you guys have believed that if you get to a certain number on the
scale,
suddenly you'll be happy and confident and free and all your dreams will come
true?
Yeah.
I kept doing that and I got down and down and down and down and never happened.
I was like,
where is this feeling?
When or where?
All the rainbows and butterflies,
I thought I was supposed to feel amazing at this number and I don't.
I still feel empty.
And it was because I hadn't really addressed the problem,
which was I didn't love myself.
So what that girl said to me on the playground,
that is what I needed to do more than anything was to actually love myself.
And what I've discovered is when you make peace with food and go on that
journey,
you're actually making peace with yourself because healing your relationship
with food is healing your relationship with yourself because your relationship
with food is a reflection of your relationship with you.
So these addictive tendencies that we have,
they are not something that we should be condemning at all,
rather these addictive tendencies.
And that could be,
you know,
emotional eating.
That could be like glass of wine at the end of a stressful day.
That could be feeling anxious,
refreshing Instagram,
which is something that I noticed that I do stuff for sure.
Um,
they're not something that we should be condemning,
but they are like our teachers shining a light on where we maybe need to look at
where our souls are actually hungry for something deeper than what we're trying
to fill it up with.
So at the time of this kind of moment of realization for me,
I was in a relationship that I didn't really feel able to fully be myself and
looks great on the outside,
but it didn't feel like me.
I was in a job that again looks quite glamorous on the outside,
but I didn't feel like it was me and I was living in a city that didn't inspire
me and all the friends that I had in my life didn't feel like real deep
friendships.
So I would say that I was living a life that did not feel completely fulfilled.
So I was turning to food and these outside sources to try and fill myself up
from the outside in instead of filling myself up from the inside out.
And when I went on this journey of self love,
what I discovered was it wasn't just about me healing my relationship with food.
It was actually about me transforming my life because then I developed such a
sense of self love and self worth.
But I had the confidence to do things like leave my relationship,
changed my life,
and then I went on to help other women do the same.
So then I wrote my book,
I started working with clients,
I wrote my online program,
started running retreats,
and it was all because I decided to take back my life when it came to food and
love and accept myself.
And around that time my ex's sister said to me,
well,
I feel sorry for you because you're just not satisfied with a normal life,
I you.
And I was like,
I'm not sure if that's an insult or a compliment,
but yeah,
you know,
I guess you're right.
I'm not satisfied with a normal life.
She said,
you're always hungry for more.
And I was like,
God damn,
you are right.
I am.
And I don't think that's a bad thing.
And I don't think I was ungrateful for what I had.
But I think if you think that your life,
if you feel like your life is not filling you up,
if you feel like you're living in a life that you should be really grateful for
and everyone else says,
oh,
you should be so lucky and grateful but you don't feel like it's yours,
you feel like there's more out there for you,
then that is your job.
That is your mission to follow that voice.
That is your mission,
to follow that call link.
So our addictions are not something that we should be condemning.
They are teachers and they can help us.
They can help guiders in the direction of where we're supposed to go.
For example,
if we can get curious about them and observe them,
they can teach us things about our life,
where we are maybe out of alignment.
So maybe for example,
you get home from a really stressful day at work and you know on the way home
you find yourself in the news agents grabbing like a chocolate bar.
So maybe that's not that you've got terrible willpower.
Maybe that is actually the root of that is stress at work.
So maybe that is I need to set more boundaries around work or I need to distress
or I need to meditate in the mornings,
or I need to decide,
make a decision that I'm not going to work with this kind of project or this
kind of,
or this person.
Or maybe it's a change of job on a bigger level.
Maybe it's you're hungry for change in your life.
Maybe if you notice that when that guy doesn't call you back or that guy doesn't
text you back,
um,
it makes you want to Benji,
all of a sudden,
maybe that's not because you were just greedy.
Maybe that's because actually what you're really hungry for on a deeper level is
love,
intimacy,
connection.
So maybe that is actually a sign that you need to give yourself more love that
you need to give yourself more time,
more intimacy with you,
and work on the relationship you have with yourself,
which is obviously the most important relationship of our whole lives.
I was walking home from a class the other day and I think it was like a 45
minute walk.
And I then Google for this because I literally have no idea how to walk anywhere
in London without Google maps.
I'm completely reliant on it.
And I came out of this class and I had to get home and my battery was on 1%
and I started walking home and I literally had no idea where I was going apart
from with these maps,
with the maps on,
and then my phone died and I instantly felt that feeling of disconnection.
And then I noticed my mind go,
oh,
go to Pratt and get a chocolate bar.
And I was like,
oh my God,
it's happening to me right now.
I just wrote a book on this.
Okay,
practice what you preach,
but just let your food,
okay,
this is teaching me that I feel disconnected when my phone dies.
Right?
This is teaching me to find a deeper connection offline.
So this is teaching me that I need to find a deeper connection with myself with
a higher power.
Get into nature,
you know,
meditate.
More things that I do to feel connected are journaling,
getting into nature,
going to the park with a book,
um,
or praying.
And so I had a little taste of my own lessons there,
which I found really interesting.
So what is really cool is addictions are not necessarily,
um,
bad.
It's really about a lack of connection or fulfillment that creates them.
So there was a study done on rats in the 70s you might have heard of them and
basically two rats were put,
sorry,
one right was alone in a cage with two bottles of water.
One was just water and one was water laced with cocaine.
And every time they run this experiment,
which was about addiction,
every time they ran this experiment,
the rats would choose the drugs,
get addicted,
and eventually die.
But professor Bruce Alexander came along.
So this experiment and thought to himself,
hmm,
well the rat is alone in a cage,
but rats are social creatures just like humans.
And they thrive off interaction,
interaction,
and connection with other rats.
So he thought if a human was alone in a cage,
wouldn't the human choose the drugs if they were offered just for something to
do?
So basically he decided to build this rat park,
which was like a haven for rats.
They had all their rat friends,
they had rat games,
they had like rat food,
they had rap love island on TV,
like they were living their best lives with these rats.
And then they put in these two bottles of water again,
the one with the water and the one with the water laced with cocaine.
Can you guess what happened?
They rejected the drugs completely.
They chose just the water and he concluded that this was because they were
living fulfilled lives.
They felt connected.
They didn't feel isolated,
they had a purpose in their lives.
So I think this is just fascinating,
and we can link this back to food or alcohol or anything else that we use as a
drug to numb our pain often.
So what this means is when you're feeling a lack of connection or a lack of
fulfillment somewhere in your life,
you pharma susceptible to those addictive tendencies.
You're far more easily led to go and grab that chocolate bar or go and have that
glass of wine or don't order that takeaway or whatever it might be.
And we all do this,
right?
It's,
we all do this,
but it's just really interesting to become aware of that and just observe it and
hopefully you can then heal what it is that you're really hungry for.
These companies,
these,
you know,
food product companies often use this,
does that to their advantage as well.
So they use our emotional attachments to food,
to market to us,
um,
in quite subtle ways.
But when you are aware of it,
it really becomes obvious.
For example,
have a break,
have a kit Kat basically saying,
your life's really tough.
You deserve a break.
Go and take the,
take a break and reward yourself with our kit Kat or Coca Cola.
Life tastes good.
Go and celebrate your life by drinking our carbonated sugary pop drunk or
Pringles.
Once you pop,
you can't stop basically normalizing it to eat a whole tub in one setting,
right?
Or maybe the worst corporate of the mall,
Mcdonald's or your kid's misbehaving again,
swing by and get them a happy meal.
That'll put a smile on their face because it's a happy meal.
Right?
So before we even six years old,
we've already got this imprinted onto our brains.
That food is there to handle our emotions,
to make us happy,
to numb our pain,
which I just find really interesting.
So I want to do a little exercise with you guys.
I would like you to get into paths.
Just partner up
and be shy and I just want you to share with your partner what that kind of one
goto emotional food is for.
You might be like crisps or chocolate or ice cream,
chips,
cheese,
whatever it might be.
What is that like?
Go to food.
Okay,
everyone done?
Everyone done?
Okay.
Everyone finished
guys?
Just one food,
one food.
Everyone's like,
I like this.
Like chocolate.
Like Chris.
It's like ice cream pizza.
Okay.
So now by the way,
my goto emotional food when I was really an emotional eater was always pick a
mix.
You know the sweets that you choose and put in a bag.
That was my thing.
I'm talking like I would go to the cinema and spend like extortion amounts on
pick and mix and not even care about seeing the film.
Okay.
So next part,
the exercise.
I want you to think about what is the earliest memory of you having that food?
What is the earliest memory of you having that food and share it with your
partner.
Okay.
Everyone done?
Next I want you to just identify what is the emotion associated with that
memory.
What is the feeling of that memory?
And share it with your partner,
not now,
but the feeling associated in that environment,
in that memory.
So share it with your partner.
Everyone got that?
Okay.
So,
um,
so
I'll share mine.
So my earliest memory of pick them eggs was my mom and dad pick him up from
school on a Friday.
Um,
and if I was really good,
then I would get pounds to spend on picnics.
And so that was like my favorite time of the all of the whole week.
And I really look forward to that because I was just so excited to get that
pound.
And so the feeling associated for me with that memory was reward and validation
for being good and it's a treat.
So in my adult life,
what I noticed that I started doing was anytime that I felt like I'd been good
or deserved a reward or a treat,
I would go get that,
pick a mix.
Um,
my partner Rick,
here's a goto emotional food was always Natala and he used to come home with a
jar of Nutella when he'd had a bad day and I'd be like,
do we need to talk about this?
Um,
but his earliest memory of Nutella was eating it on pancakes with his mum.
And so he,
uh,
associated that with love and connection.
So when he felt like he needed love and connection,
he would go get that in a teller because food feels like love.
Right.
So does anyone want to share?
What does,
why?
Just a couple of people.
Anyone?
Yeah.
Mine was my continues.
Uh Huh.
Mine was my countries.
I remember eating it at home with my mom.
My brother and my sister.
Just like having a good time,
like just the happy memory.
Yeah.
So then if you in your adult life,
then if you feel like you need to go to a happy place,
that is the,
the is the happy place.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Thank you for sharing.
Anyone else want to share?
Everyone say shy.
Anyone else?
One more?
I can share mine.
Okay.
Think you,
yeah.
Mine was Sushi and I kind of discovered it when I was doing a year abroad in New
Orleans and when I was 20 and it was just a really happier and have many fun and
carefree and I ended up eating it every day and it would give my cure for
everything.
Hangovers.
Yeah.
Yes.
It just became this finny.
Yup.
Jovie full food symbolize like joy.
Yeah.
That's a really fun,
awesome.
Thank you for sharing.
Another really common thing is,
yeah,
if we weren't allowed it at home as kids,
then when we grow up in West said and the adults and free and liberated,
we're like,
oh my God,
I can get,
I can eat it now.
I'm allowed to eat whatever I want.
So it's like symbolizes this rebellion and this freedom and independence.
So,
um,
food is,
uh,
food is parallel to our life.
So,
you know,
our relationship with food can be this kind of comfort,
this emotional tool,
but it can also be pleasure.
And I think when we get sucked into diet land,
we forget that we were allowed to receive pleasure and joy from food.
It's allowed to be a completely celebrated,
celebrated tree experience.
And a good question to ask yourself when you're,
when you're turning to food is,
am I using this to celebrate or am I using it to escape?
Because often we're actually trying to push down a feeling.
Um,
so yeah,
our relationship with food is a reflection of our relationship with life,
which means you know that saying like how you do one thing is how you do
everything.
So it's kind of like how you do food is often how you do life.
So if you are a perfectionist around your food,
you're probably also a perfectionist in your life.
If you are controlling around food,
you're probably also controlling in life.
And who's like an all or nothing person.
Anyone here like totally all or nothing.
So if you're all or nothing with food,
you've probably all also all or nothing in your life and your relationships and
your job or projects.
And who here would can say that they are a fast eater?
Everyone.
Yeah.
This doesn't surprise me.
Right?
Cause you guys are like high achievers.
So if you're a fast eater you're probably also going through your life quite
fast,
which is why it's difficult to get people to slow down there eating because it's
basically like saying slow down your life pace.
Do you also drive your car quite fast if you drive?
Did you go through your life quite fast in other areas?
Yeah.
So what this means is when we are able to heal our stuff with food,
we can also heal our life.
And if we're able to enjoy a more intuitive way of eating,
it means we're more likely to enjoy an intuitive way of living.
So I always say intuitive eating paves the way for intuitive living.
When I was able to learn how to really listen to my body,
I was also able to learn how to listen to my gut.
I was able to learn how to listen to my intuition.
I realized that the two went hand in hand.
So a lot of people think that when they're going to listen to their body,
they think that their body is just telling them to eat all kinds of junk and
it's simply not the case.
So I want to explain to you guys just to finish the difference between your real
hunger and your emotional cravings.
So real hunger comes on very gradually,
slowly,
and you feel it here,
right?
You feel it in the stomach and it gives you the time and that patience to go,
what am I hungry for?
What am I going to choose to nourish my body?
Whereas an emotional craving is actually a psychological need and it comes on
very fast in the mind.
And it's that urge.
It's that impulse and it usually fixates on one particular kind of food.
So it comes on really fast.
And if you don't check yourself,
you kind of like glaze over when you become this Zombie state.
And before you know it you've eaten something and you don't even know how you
got there.
If we were doing that with drugs,
it'd be a pretty big problem,
right?
But we do that with food a lot.
So when we have those psychological cravings,
what we're actually craving is something deeper,
usually love,
usually connection and all of those things that we can,
that we are craving,
we can give to ourselves.
We can never truly get it,
Matt,
to get those needs met from someone else,
a food or drink a substance,
um,
social media,
all of these kind of external things.
It's a way in which we tried to fill ourselves up from the outside in rather
than filling ourselves up from the inside out and fulfillment and living a truly
full up life.
So thank you.
I hope this has given you some food for thought and that you will be able to
hopefully bring a little bit more awareness to your relationship with food and
use it to your advantage.
Thank you.
Do we have ton of time for Q and.
A,
you have to speak into this because we're recording this for youtube.
Does anyone have questions?
Thank you so much.
Um,
I think speaking for all of us,
we all really enjoyed that.
Um,
I've got a question and I'm not sure if you're gonna be able to answer it,
but it's to do with the whole sort of body positive intuitive eating movement
mean.
A lot of my friends,
we have a lot of intolerances which really hinders our ability to eat freely.
And I often feel like that's not,
um,
taken into consideration into the body positive and intuitive eating movement.
Yeah.
And I would just like,
just like to hear your thoughts on it really.
Yeah.
You know,
gluten free,
dairy free,
things like that.
Sure,
sure.
Thank you so much.
So first of all,
I would like to offer that the body positive movement is diff is a separate
thing from intuitive eating and you can do one without the other and vice versa.
Um,
so I would say that,
I mean the body positive movement is a movement in itself and the people that
kind of started that have their own definition of what that is and what they
stand for.
But you can decide that for you to be positive for your body,
for you to show your body love means to not have things that don't agree with
it.
So for example,
like I consider myself to be body positive because I do positive things for my
body.
Did you know what I mean?
Although I'm not a part necessarily of that movement and the real,
the roots of it obviously were different from,
from what,
where I'm sad.
Um,
but if doing a positive thing for your body is not having certain foods that
don't agree with it,
then that's absolutely great.
I don't think intuitive eating is about,
you know,
just eating rubbish all the time.
I think it's about noticing what feels good and what doesn't.
And that's definitely something that I've learned along my journey because I
thought that going into intuitive eating would mean that I would just gain loads
of weight and would just sit around eating,
you know,
donuts and ice cream and all kinds of,
cereal for dinner and all this kind of stuff.
And it's not what happened.
I think initially there might be like a boomerang phase where you're just like,
oh my God,
freedom.
But then after that,
what happens is you start to recognize what feels good and what doesn't.
And you start to notice that actually it feels really good to have this amount
of vegetables and it feels really good to have me or to not have meat.
And it feels really good to have gluten auto not have gluten.
And it's really about you taking your power back around food and not thinking
that it has to look a certain way.
It's about you becoming the boss of your own body.
Thank you so much.
That was it.
Yeah.
Cool.
Hi.
Yes,
thank you so much for the talk,
um,
as well as to know a little bit more.
And if you're comfortable sharing,
but just your transition between,
you talked about your veganism,
your perfectionism to kind of,
to the state that you are now and um,
if you've,
I've heard that,
you know,
kind of all we all know like you know,
the path to whatever's kind of looks like this and yeah.
You had a few of these debts are and how you overcame those and how you also got
to the state that you're in now.
Sure.
Do you mean like from disordered or being in tall you are present.
Yeah,
sure.
So it was definitely like a bumpy road to begin with because when you are so
ingrained,
ingrained in that diet culture,
you feel like it's like a lot of your identity is wrapped up in it.
So I didn't really know who I was without a diet cause it consumed so much of my
life.
So getting myself that freedom to break free from that felt like I was
rediscovering who I was and almost like creating a new identity for myself
because it had taken up so much head space that when I got rid of that I was
like,
oh my God,
I don't know what to do with myself anymore.
Cause it was like,
it was like a full time job for me dieting.
So coming out of that was definitely a bumpy road,
but I just kept focusing on,
I'm getting my life back here.
So even though to begin with,
I gained way.
I also gained my life back,
which was so much more important to me.
Um,
but yeah,
I definitely had to figure out all of these different beliefs and stories that I
was telling myself around different diets and food and the people that I
followed.
I had to unfollow a lot of people that were just kind of projecting their
beliefs out onto social media.
And I was like,
that's not helpful for me.
For where I'm at right now.
I just need to be able to make my own intuitive decisions around food rather
than listening to every single expert that's got a different opinion on food.
I just needed to like block all that out to just come home to my body.
And that really helped me.
But for sure it was a bumpy road.
And,
um,
yeah,
I did,
I realized along that road that veganism wasn't for me anymore.
And you know,
me deciding to be a Vegan,
my intention behind that wasn't as it should have been.
It was because I thought it was the perfect diet and because I thought it would
heal me and make me lose weight as opposed to what actually feels good.
And I have a lot of friends that are Vegan,
but they do it for much more,
um,
ethical reasons.
But personally for me,
I feel good when I have a bit of animal products in my lifestyle.
Um,
and I don't think anyone should be shamed for that.
Cool.
Well,
thanks again.